mcdonald's selling out of burgers due to
massive popularity of travis scott's
meal controlling supply strategy
mcdonald's uses to prevent
shortages it did so uh when meat
processing plants
were closed earlier this year however
this is the first time during the
pandemic that mcdonald's has
actually run out of ingredients in a
shortage sparked by massive demand and
not pandemic related
supply chain disruptions the shortages
are remarkably because the meal is made
up of mcdonald's classics a quarter
pounder with cheese fries and with
barbecue sauce and sprite
we're working closely with our suppliers
distributors and franchisees to resupply
and pack that
restaurants as quickly as possible how
does mcdonald's run out of supply
is travis scott that big of a deal adam
let me tell you something
other than drake in my opinion travis
scott is the number one rapper on the
planet right now
he's causing mcdonald's to run out of
burgers
do you know the last time that
mcdonald's had a celebrity
person like this that they were
endorsing a celebrity meal do you know
the last person the hamburglar the
the hamburglar good call the last person
to have a celebrity meal on
michael jordan boom michael jordan shout
out to tom zennifer again that 1992
mcdonald's has not partnered up with a
celebrity since 1992
to do this people are going in full but
the story is a great story how would
happen why don't you tell us the story
of how it happened
he goes into mcdonald's yeah tell us i
don't know how he goes
you guys were talking about him he kind
of goes in there and he has this meal
named after him which
i was anxious to find out what it is
it's a quarter pounder it's a sprite and
it's fries it's nothing fancy but
you're saying how the meal ended up
naming after him or just like he went to
mcdonald's the other day and people were
going crazy people were going crazy you
were going crazy yes
to to use a travis scott song people
were in complete
sicko mode that's the number one song
you know
they got goosebumps every time he comes
around you know i could see
i could see how they could cause
shortages though because look i mean
it's six bucks that's what the meal is
that's cheap i mean once you know that
if you're a travis scott fan
six bucks anybody can afford that
business model works so good why has
mcdonald's waited 28 years to do that i
think they got lucky i think this one
i mean but but but travis scott is not
the biggest thing why hasn't the rock
done a deal with them
why hasn't kevin hart done a deal with
them why hasn't drake done a deal with
them why hasn't kanye done a deal with
them
why haven't a lot why hasn't lebron done
to deal with them well maybe lebron
would think the brand has been
i mean maybe some celebrities i don't
think so i don't think so no i mean
listen
lebron if you offer him two and a half
million dollars
going to say hey i'll consider that i
mean mcdonald's is not going to come up
with a little number mcdonald's going to
give you a few million
you better believe travis scott got a
big check with mcdonald's collaboration
i'll tell you what i don't
you know there's something about travis
scott
he's not out there in the public like
how the rock is out there
listen to me man and he's not out there
how kevin hart is out he doesn't do a
lot of things he does his music got it
he does his thing
so now he's doing his mcdonald's and
people like what the hell is going on
here travis
he i know that you're not a fan of his
music the guy is completely
he made it's lit popular that's great
that was him
good and and his girl is apparently a
billionaire
his girl is kylie jenner ain't so bad i
mean i think that's how a lot of people
associate him as kylie jenner's no no no
no a lot of people do no i'm not saying
someone like you would be like oh it's
kylie jenner's husband that's this guy
travis scott was a known commodity
before he started banging uh kylie
jenner but see i knew enough to know
that they were never married
so not technically her husband
[Music]